hi i'm al gore and as some of you may
know i'm one of those who's been working
to raise awareness of the climate crisis
for quite some time
15 years ago i was lucky to work with a
great director davis guggenheim and an
incredible team of filmmakers on a
documentary called an inconvenient truth
about the urgent need for action on
climate
in the years since we've made
significant progress in developing the
solutions we need to solve this crisis
but unfortunately the impacts of the
climate crisis are still getting worse
faster than we are yet deploying these
solutions but we have the power to
change that
we've finally reached the political
tipping point beyond which we can unlock
real action
in order for us to actually cross this
tipping point we need all of you
by joining us today you've taken the
first step in driving this progress i
hope the ideas you'll learn about here
will inspire you to continue taking
action in your own community
if we work together there's a wonderful
future ahead of us so let's get going
welcome to countdown
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the countdown stage here's
charlie puth
here we are
on earth
together it's you
and i
god has made us fall
in love
it's true
i really
found someone like you
will it say
the love you feel from me oh will
you say
that you will be here by my side
to see
me through
until
my life is thrown
well in my mind
we can conquer the world
you and i
i am glad
at least in my life i found
someone
that may not be here
[Music]
me forever
but i
found strength
i only pray
that i have shown you a
brighter day
because that's all that i am living for
you see
don't worry
what happens to me
cause in my mind
you will stay here always
[Music]
we can conquer the world
you and
[Music]
thank you charlie puss it's my pleasure
ladies
um
[Music]
i think we're gonna maybe see you at the
flip side yeah you're gonna see me on
the flip side absolutely okay well
thanks for uh sticking around no it's my
pleasure i'm a climate advocate so i'm
very very excited to be here and i'm
sticking around for the show like you
said you got one more song out of me um
i'll be back in a little bit all right
they told me to go behind you okay
thanks charlie
um
people of earth hello this is countdown
i'm your host lucif nasser some of you
may know me as the co-host of radio lab
or the host of the netflix series
connected uh but i'm also a ted speaker
we are coming to you live from the ted
world theater in new york city welcome
to all of you joining from around this
blue green marble uh whether you just
woke up in san francisco or you just
finished lunch in sao paulo or dinner in
soweto or if you're watching from your
bed in shanghai we're all here
for the same reason
our house
is on fire
and we need to put it out tackling
climate change is the issue of our
moment and this initiative right here
countdown uh is focused on the people
the ideas the solutions the actions that
we need to set us right
the situation is urgent no doubt but as
you're about to see
we're still in the game
over the next two hours you're gonna see
some heartening examples of innovation
and leadership true stories and honest
sentiments that'll give hope as well as
a sense of how each and every one of us
can make an impact you'll hear excerpts
from ted countdown talks by scientists
activists entrepreneurs artists
policymakers business leaders from all
over including uh from the countdown
summit in edinburgh scotland earlier
this month plus
you'll never guess who volunteered to
speak up about saving the planet a bunch
of the most talented performers on said
planet including regina hall rooney mara
joaquin phoenix michaela j rodriguez
mark ruffalo forest whitaker um actor
rayne wilson gathered a bunch of his
funniest friends and made something for
us uh we've also got performances by
dave matthews valerie june charlie puth
as he said he's coming back uh to take
the stage once again now
i know
trust me i know that hearing about
climate change can sometimes feel
at the same time like
cataclysmic
and
overwhelming but then also kind of
boring and like homework uh
today we are not gonna do that we're
gonna do something different take a look
[Music]
there's a story we've been writing
together for hundreds of years
[Music]
it's about all of us
it takes place
right here
it started for many of us as economies
were built
but growth rooted in extracting from our
planet and our people came at a cost
there were warning signs
some of us knew what was happening to
our communities wasn't right that it was
connected to something bigger
and the impacts were felt by some more
than others
people organized and asked questions
others tried to understand what was
happening and sounded the alarm even as
others refused to believe what we told
them
that the planet's climate is changing
our story has heroes big and small
maybe you even became a hero in your own
way
it's a story of hope persistence a plan
for a better future
there's also despair denial
and relentless crisis
while there are forces that seek to
divide or distract us we choose to act
now
this story has many possibilities
futures that we write first as neighbors
and then as a movement
we are coming together
choosing what comes next
isn't just urgent and necessary it is
possible already underway and leading us
to a better future
countdown is a global initiative to
champion and accelerate solutions to the
climate crisis
to turn ideas into action because in
spite of all the challenges people never
stop trying to shift mindsets and then
entire systems investors they think the
future is green we have 10 years to
change it so we need to act all together
right now to change the way we move
ourselves and our economy transformation
in every global system from agriculture
to retail shipping to trucking cement to
steel and the very foundations upon
which we live a big detox of
transportation is possible
electrification will permeate everything
a phase out of internal combustion
engines educating and empowering women
and girls is one of the single most
important things that we can do to
confront carbon pollution everyone must
get to a zero-carbon future when we
connect our stories and play an active
part
our imaginations are the only limit in
radical collaboration with each other we
can do this and while we're at it let's
make it just and fair for everyone
no matter what has gone wrong
what can go right the solution is to
build a new coalition made up of all the
groups most affected which story gets in
the way of you taking action challenge
that story
our story takes place here
it's been difficult at times
and could have unthinkable outcomes
but that was the story we used to tell
now it's up to us
to tell a new one
big thanks to don cheadle who is the
voice you just heard and i want to bring
in another voice uh ted science curator
david biello david's been a climate
journalist for two decades wrote a book
about solutions to the environmental
challenges we face um
i wanted to have him here for the next
two hours to kind of break things down
be sort of a cheat sheet for people like
me who are not super well steeped in
this field so um before we dive in can
you just give us a like a primer like
what do we need to know before we go
forward okay so
climate change
is
this problem where the earth's average
temperature is warming up that's why you
sometimes hear it called global warming
why is it warming up well it's because
of these little things called greenhouse
gases they're called greenhouse gases
because they trap the earth's heat just
like the greenhouse in your garden right
it's warmer in there so you'll also hear
this kind of wonky phrase called
decarbonization and that's because most
of the greenhouse gases have carbon in
them so we've got to get rid of the
greenhouse gases we got to decarbonize
and the main way we're going to do that
is by putting no more greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere then we take out
and that's called net zero net zero so
we're
counting down that's what countdown is
all about counting down to net zero you
got it got it uh throughout the show
you'll be seeing parts of ted countdown
talks that'll help frame the problem in
a way that even i can understand um and
that can provide a blueprint for
what our future could look like uh here
to introduce our first set of great big
green ideas is a great man whom you
likely know for being big and green
mark ruffalo
hi i'm mark ruffalo
i became an environmental activist when
energy companies wanted to frack for gas
near my home in upstate new york
and i learned how doctors scientists and
members of my community were coming
together to protect the water from
contamination
it seemed overwhelming at the time
but i also realized that something could
be done that i i i could actually join
the fight
and
that's the message that i i want to
share with you today
that despite the scope of the climate
crisis we're confronting today there
there is hope
climate change does it threatens the
overall health of our planet but people
are actually coming together in
neighborhoods all across the globe to
solve this crisis
it is more urgent now than ever that
governments and industries actually
listen to the people and take decisive
action
but there are many paths forward and
there are actually things that we can do
today to help we're at a critical
crossroads
but
the choices that lie ahead of us
there are real opportunities
and we as a global community have never
been better positioned to fight this
crisis we have the knowledge we have the
innovation and we have the technology we
have the financial means
now
all we need is a collaboration and a
commitment to show up for each other for
the future that we want to create
and these next ten countdown speakers
are here to remind us of just that that
together we can find a global local and
personal
solution
to forge a path forward
for a healthier tomorrow
take a look
[Music]
touch down anywhere in the world and
you'll hear more tragic stories of
climate devastation
droughts
floods wildfires lives and livelihoods
in jeopardy
tipping towards catastrophe
and yet despite it all i still have hope
in our human family
and you might ask why
it's our capacity for human endeavor to
survive against all odds
one that created the extraordinary
promise of the un paris agreement
and its power to drive the 17
sustainable development goals for people
and for planet
we know that the promise of paris aims
to limit global heating to 1.5 degrees
to ensure that we survive as a human
family
to get there we know exactly what we
must do
we must decarbonize the global economy
by 2050
by way of halving the emissions in this
decade
we must make coal history with coal
phased out in rich countries by 2030
and in other countries by 2040.
the g20 produces 80 percent of all
greenhouse gas pollution
and so they too must these 20 global
leaders take responsibility and lead
we must stop spending trillions
subsidizing fossil fuels clogging the
lungs of our people and destroying
forests and oceans
and we must provide the resources that
are needed for a just green and blue
transition
we know that these are all essential
ingredients to fulfill the paris
agreement
now try to reimagine with me
what this journey to net zero emissions
could look like through another lens
one that puts our focus on investing in
people to reach their potentials while
protecting our home planet earth
decarbonization a powerful vehicle for
climate action
but also for delivering on the 17
sustainable development goals
we need to change the way we think about
the climate challenge
because things are different this time
we need to stop thinking about it just
as a problem which it obviously is
and start thinking about it as an
opportunity which will motivate us to
solve it
i'm a venture investor i invest in early
stage companies and technologies
and i see tremendous opportunities in
solving climate change
that said we've been here before and
it's different this time
we can reduce net emissions to zero
and that was not obvious even just 10
years ago
why do i think it's different
because we have cheaper inputs we have
better technologies we have better
policies we have a better
sense of urgency and most important of
all we have even better people working
on it
how do we shift out of despair
out of denial
towards something radically different
there's a quote in spider-man
with great power comes great
responsibility
yet what if the opposite is true
what if it's really
with great responsibility
comes great power
this is something that all of the
world's movers and shakers have known to
be true
they weren't born leaders
they simply decided to make themselves
personally responsible
now solving climate change
is not your responsibility
because it's outside of your control
what you are responsible for
is the thing inside your control indeed
the only thing that has ever been inside
your control
your mindset
we all have stories running on repeat
stories that immobilize us stories the
world impresses upon us
in boardrooms and classrooms alike
i'm just one in 7.8 billion people i'm
too small to make a difference
i'm not smart enough i don't have the
experience i'm not the expert
the system is too broken our leader is
too short-sighted
our society too shackled to the status
quo
these stories
paralyze us
rewriting them
is the single most powerful thing any
one of us can do
for the planet and for ourselves
what's the plan john
the plan
is to transform society
and what do you mean by that transformed
society
i thought you might ask that
there are six big objectives
we're going to electrify transportation
which means stop using diesel and gas
for our vehicles
we're going to decarbonize the grid
with wind and solar and nuclear
third
we're going to
fix our food systems and that includes
eating less meat and dairy
reducing food waste and improving our
soil health
fourth we're going to protect nature
that's stopping deforestation
protecting our oceans protecting our
peatlands our grasslands
fifth we're going to clean up our
materials how we make things like cement
and steel
and then sixth
we're gonna have to figure out ways to
remove the carbon that remains that
stubborn residual
effects of emissions that cannot be
eliminated
every one of these six things is a major
challenge we've got to attack them all
at once we have 85 percent of the
solutions that we need
record lows of solar and wind prices
means deployments around the world the
dropping cost of lithium-ion batteries
means we're seeing more electric
vehicles but those solutions alone won't
get us to net zero and so
we're going to have to both deploy and
invest in the now as well as invent the
new so we need the now and the new we
need to scale up what we have as well as
invest in the future
climate change
amplifies inequities
those who suffer the most have done the
least to cause this problem
and what that means is that the us as
the world's historic biggest emitter
must decarbonize first
we've got to do that for two reasons to
show the world that it's possible
and to drive the cost down for everyone
else
individual actions are needed
and expected
but they are not going to get us where
we need to go in this the decisive
decade
when
we have to cut emissions in half by
2030.
[Music]
the good news is
we can do this
we have the knowledge
we have the technology we know it makes
social and economic sense and when we
succeed we can all take lung fulls of
fresh air we will be saying hello to
healthy lifestyles and resilient
economies in livable cities
we are all on this journey around the
sun together
this is our only home
this is our mission
to protect our children's future
thank you to mark ruffalo and all those
ted countdown speakers
uh
david i i know a lot of people see
climate change headlines and it just
kind of feels like the same thing
over and over
why is this moment different
so
one big reason this moment is different
is because the science is is ever more
clear we know more and another reason
this moment is different is because we
know where the problem is coming from
even more so we're burning too many
fossil fuels that's coal oil and gas and
we're cutting down too many forests to
uh to feed ourselves but because we know
where the problems are coming from we
know also how to solve them
we've got to get off the fossil sunshine
trapped in those fossil fuels get off
that fossil sunshine and get on the
fresh stuff
i'm sure many of you who are watching
have questions for david2 you can put
them in the chat below or you can tweet
them using the hashtag tedcountdown and
actually to get ahead of what i expect
some of those questions are going to be
uh
so much of the story of climate change
is the story of carbon and the story of
carbon above us in the atmosphere the
ted team made this
gorgeous explainer to help parts it all
out so take a look
the air we breathe has changed the mix
of gases is shifting with more and more
greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide and
this shift is happening faster each year
in fact concentrations of co2 have
reached levels never before breathed by
humans since homo sapiens evolved
in just a few hundred years eons of
fossilized sunshine have been burned as
coal oil and gas
the exhaust has transformed the entire
atmosphere and ocean it's like a
pollution blanket and the result we know
as climate change
so how much more of that fossilized
sunshine can we burn before further
destabilizing the earth's systems
not much
think of it as a carbon budget we are
currently adding 55 billion metric tons
of greenhouse gases to the atmosphere
every year
this is the gigaton challenge
by some estimates at that pace we will
have burned through the remaining budget
by 2030 so to give us some room to
breathe the world must reduce greenhouse
gas pollution by more than seven percent
each year every year of this decade
starting now
there are a number of ways to do that
let's start by looking at the greenhouse
gases themselves
co2 makes up nearly 75 of the pollution
emitted each year
there's also nitrous oxide known as
laughing gas but it's no laughing matter
seeping out of farm fields and elsewhere
and making up six percent of the problem
and then there's methane which you may
also know of as natural gas it's 17 of
the total
there are other greenhouse gases but
these three make up the bulk of the
climate challenge
all must be reduced and fast
methane is better at trapping the sun's
heat which means cutting methane
pollution is a necessary and fast acting
stimulus for our carbon budget
if methane emissions from agriculture
and the oil and gas industry can be
eliminated in this decade we might be
able to stave off catastrophes like the
loss of the arctic sea ice and glaciers
all around the world
co2 has a longer life once it is added
to the atmosphere it can stay up there
for hundreds of years if not longer
co2 emissions must be cut in half by
2030 and then reduced even further by
2040 to put the world on a path of
adding no more co2 to the air by 2050.
and that means transforming the modern
world as quickly as possible
there are several ways to break down the
sources of greenhouse gas emissions here
we're using the public climate watch
data
start with energy the majority of modern
energy comes from fossil fuels which
makes the energy sector 76 of the
climate challenge including the fuels
used for transportation industrial
processes and agricultural production
the shift to clean energy must be
accelerated by an order of magnitude if
we want any chance to restrain global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
and we'll need more ways to store this
clean electricity whether that's putting
it in the chemical bonds of a battery or
into a molecule of hydrogen
batteries in clean hydrogen are also
going to play a key role in cleaning up
transportation which accounts for 17 of
climate changing pollution including the
use of energy to move people and goods
around
eight percent from cars five percent
from trucks and other heavy-duty
vehicles and four percent from shipping
and aviation
with abundant clean electricity the
world can win the race to electrify cars
and create cleaner alternative fuels for
trucks ships and even one day airplanes
then there are our lifestyles and the
materials that make them possible that's
everything from the cement and steel
that go into buildings to the plastic
fibers in fashion
all told these materials account for six
percent of our emissions on top of the
energy emissions required to produce
them
and we'll need new and clean ways to
make them or replace them
farming and animal raising also have to
change as agriculture accounts for 12 of
greenhouse gas pollution that means
everything from how and what people eat
to how and what cows chickens and pigs
eat it also means finding ways for farm
fields to go from sources of greenhouse
gas to places where greenhouse gases get
buried
agriculture is also the biggest direct
impact people have on the plants animals
microbes and fungi that share this
planet with us
to truly solve the climate challenge the
wild world will have to be protected and
restored to allow all of life's myriad
forms to flourish
a halt in cutting down forests burning
peatlands and converting coastal
wetlands could prevent the release of
nearly 5 billion metric tons of
greenhouse gases each year
restoring nearly 200 million hectares of
degraded forest land peatland and
wetlands could also absorb almost
another 4 billion metric tons
perhaps even more importantly the ocean
has vast potential to help reduce
greenhouse gases
if we protect it
finally there are technologies being
developed to draw down co2 from the
atmosphere because we have already
emitted too much but very few of these
machine forests have been deployed and
they are too expensive to scale up
faster right now
this is the climate challenge we face
going from adding 55 billion metric tons
of greenhouse gases to the air each year
to adding zero by 2050 at the latest
the countdown begins now
[Music]
now david i'll i'll be honest like i i
just find it so hard to conceptualize
this like 55 billion
metric tons like that's a heavy thing
of greenhouse greenhouse gas that's a
light thing so if it's a lot it has to
be a lot of a light thing to make up
that much of heavy but like so that's a
lot
um
and then we have to get half of that by
2030 none of that by 2050
like for a lot a lot
is that even possible
look it's uh it's a big problem i'm not
going to lie and honestly we're not
going in the right direction that 55
billion number is still growing so it's
getting to be a bigger problem but the
reality is climate change is already
here we have all the tools we need to
address this problem so yes
yes and and but it sounds like getting
to that yes is it's uh gonna take a
mighty effort uh thank you david um now
let's welcome an amazing activist and
leader the reverend lennox yearwood
president and ceo of the hip-hop caucus
climate justice ensures that the
injustice of the climate crisis meaning
that those who have benefited from
fossil fuels for years and decades
that the injustice that was caused upon
their community that is being caused
upon their community that they can find
justice that they can find resolve in
regards to the aspect of changing from
fossil fuels to clean energy the aspect
of when they are dealing with energy
poverty in their community when they are
paying more for the utility bills they
can transition to clean electricity
standards in their community climate
justice means also a just transition so
that when we transition from fossil
fuels to clean energy that we transition
in a way that that helps all communities
that we don't prop up this system of
white supremacy or this system of
colonialism that
that takes away the power from those
communities but we do it in a way that
allows for all communities to be lifted
up
that's the most amazing part about this
crisis
the most amazing part about this crisis
is that it brings us all together black
white brown red male female straight gay
theist atheists
humans
this crisis has forced us to bring
all of us together and the only way that
we win this crisis
that we all come together if we don't
come together as humans we lose
and so that's the moment that we're in
that's the word that we have to get out
there and we can solve it together
but divide it
we fail
thank you reverend yearwood
climate change does affect
literally every person on the planet and
racial injustice poverty mass migration
natural disasters even pandemics these
are all connected and climate change is
making
all of them worse
now this is the spot where i usually
start to spiral into despair and so to
pull myself and all of us out of that
i'm going to throw to a man who is
either the
funniest climate activist i can think of
or the climate activistist comedian i
can think of
rayne wilson
greetings people of the ted universe
it's me rain wilson and listen i reached
out to some of the funniest people on
the planet and asked them this very
interesting and challenging question is
there anything funny about climate
change is there anything funny about
climate change is there anything funny
about climate change there's so much
it's hilarious i mean
rising seas and crops failing and forest
fires devastating huge tracks of the
earth i mean the list goes on and on and
on i personally think that humor could
be found in absolutely anything i think
with the subject like climate change
it's a lot tougher because it's a
serious matter but there's definitely
humor in there
and i will give you an example
um
okay something funny about climate
change
um
here's give me a second
my hometown of duluth minnesota is going
to be the new monaco
uh what was once uh
a punch line i tell you is now a place
of refuge
uh from the fire tornadoes
yay deloath
oh
i live in new jersey so we got the
jersey shore which will sadly be washed
away here's the thing i am in
mississippi right now and i came outside
so that i could make this video and
there is the funny image of you know
everybody's watched jersey shore and
seen those people the fist pumping spray
tans since they were nine years old and
then they'll get washed out to see
flopping around like orange butterfly
humans
with their spiky hair
protruding from the surface of the water
like shark fins
and everybody fighting to survive
[Music]
so that makes me laugh
it would be
funny uh if i had a heat stroke and died
while making a video
about the climate that would be funny
i hope that doesn't happen
okay
okay um
wait no that's not funny
[Music]
okay so they didn't really answer the
question but we'll bring back rain and
his friends later to try again uh now
here to introduce key moments from his
this next group of ted countdown talks
is the founder of the whitaker peace and
development initiative
forest whitaker everyone
hello i'm force whitaker
climate change is the defining global
challenge of our time
affecting every continent every country
and every person
scientists tell us we need to
dramatically reduce emissions and make
the world net zero by 2050 or sooner
but what does net zero mean exactly
as we've heard we're currently pumping
55 billion tons of planet
greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide and
methane into our atmosphere each year
that's seven tons for each person on the
planet the largest source of those
emissions globally is the burden of coal
gas and oil for heat and electricity
other sources include transportation
industry buildings and agriculture
once up in the atmosphere those gases
don't dissolve they accumulate
progressively creating a pollution
blanket that warms the planet if we
don't take action rising sea levels and
extreme weather events will wreck
economies and displace millions of
people
inequality and poverty will be
reinforced around the world causing in
turn upheavals and eventually armed
conflicts the work of my foundation in
some of the most vulnerable places in
the world i've seen firsthand the
devastating consequences that climate
change can have on our communities but
we can reduce emissions to ensure that
we're not contributing more to the
atmosphere than we and nature can take
out that is net zero and it's central to
getting us out of danger and on the path
to a better healthier peaceful more
equitable future
these next ted countdown speakers will
share innovative solutions from around
the world to both reduce and remove
greenhouse gases
whether it's innovative social
organizing or cutting edge technology
we need all hands on deck
[Music]
climate policy and agreements they're
complicated
but what's simple
is that the majority of emissions
that are trapped in our atmosphere today
well they come from three products
oil
gas
and coal
for decades
our countries have been negotiating
targets
but behind our backs the fossil fuel
industry has been growing production
and locking in further emissions
i started reaching out to climate policy
experts from around the world
because i wanted to understand
what frameworks exist
to negotiate who gets to produce what
and how much what policies help
governments regulate constrain the
production side of fossil fuels
i found out that very few do
we have more than enough fossil fuels
in existing installations even if we
stopped expansion today
of oil gas and coal and existing
projects to use while we carefully
manage a phase down
and so
the world
is spending its intellectual
its financial
its technical capital
to dig up stuff
that we know we can't burn
and if we do
it will burn us
so what do we do
a year ago a group of academics
advocates scientists and former
diplomats came together to create the
fossil fuel non-proliferation treaty
initiative
to create the missing framework
so countries can negotiate a wind down
of fossil fuels in a way that is fair
in a way that is equitable
[Music]
so here's the good news
support for the treaty is growing
every day i'm so excited to turn on my
computer
101 nobel laureates including the dalai
lama have endorsed the principles of a
fossil fuel treaty
cities from around the world are passing
motions at their city councils to
endorse a fossil fuel treaty sydney
barcelona
l.a vancouver
a hundred over a hundred elected
officials from around the world from 20
countries starting in the global south
have endorsed the principles of a fossil
fuel treaty
over 2 000 scientists have now endorsed
the principles of a fossil fuel treaty
indigenous leaders
youth groups over 800 civil society
organizations who have been fighting
fossil fuel projects for decades
are now calling on their governments
to negotiate a treaty to keep it in the
ground
a fossil fuel treaty will help us wind
down the production of fossil fuels
it will provide a complement and help us
achieve the goals of the paris accord
it is a big bold new idea
but at this moment in history
we need some big bold new ideas
in the time it took me to walk on stage
around 10 seconds more than 10 000
metric tons of climate warming gases
have been pumped into the atmosphere
from human actions
99 of this pollution is carbon dioxide
co2 and we know we need to reduce it
the other 1
is almost entirely methane which mostly
comes from producing fossil fuels
managing waste and raising livestock
but that one percent of methane could
cause more warming over the next 10
years than all that co2
this is because methane absorbs a lot
more energy per unit mass for reasons
relating to its molecular structure
and its ability to form other greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere
co2 is important because it can linger
in the atmosphere long after it is
emitted which means we must achieve net
zero emissions to eventually stabilize
our climate
this is key for protecting generations
to come
but with climate change already
devastating so many lives today
we can't focus only on the distant
future
my work as a scientist aims to identify
ways to slow down worming as fast as
possible so that we can lower the risks
of worsening damages in the near future
this is where methane comes in
that one percent of methane may cause
more warming than all that co2 in the
next several years but it only lasts in
the atmosphere for around a decade
methane's warming power is therefore not
from the gradual buildup over time like
co2
but almost entirely from recent
emissions
this means that every time we reduce
methane we can reduce a lot of warming
right away
in fact
cutting methane is the single fastest
most effective opportunity to
immediately slow down the rate of
warming
and this is because not only does
methane act fast but because we can act
fast because we have the technologies
available right now to cut methane
emissions from human activities in half
and even better
many of these solutions pay for
themselves
pasture is the single largest type of
land on the surface of the earth today
thanks to our
taste for meat and dairy
just over a quarter of all land is used
for livestock that's more than forests
or farm fields or anything else
most of that land
is best for ruminants such as cows
that can digest high fiber feed such as
grass and straw
however the process by which grass and
fiber is broken up in the stomachs of
cows and other grazing ruminants has a
by-product methane
a potent greenhouse gas
despite what you might have heard about
methane and cows most of the methane is
actually burnt out not to the back end
and that represents about two billion
tons of carbon dioxide equivalent per
year or more than four percent of our
annual global greenhouse gas emissions
we have a methane problem from cows
so how can you reduce these methane
burps
my colleagues and i may have found a
solution
seaweed
so how does it work
some series contain ingredients
that
directly inhibit microbes in the cow's
gut from forming methane without
interfering with food digestion
the amount of methane produced
is
dependent on how much the animal is
eating and what's in the diet and as
such
previous efforts to reduce methane
emissions focus on changing the diet or
improving forage quality
and we do have
potential solutions other than seaweeds
to reduce methane emissions
molecular additives to feed such as
three nlp reduce emissions by about 30
percent
even garlic and citrus extract
can reduce methane burps by over 20
percent without affecting animal health
and productivity
now you may ask
why not stop eating beef and drinking
milk
that would be a good question
so adopting a plant-based diet
with supplements
may help shrink a person's carbon
footprint
in high income countries like the us
but for the rest of the world these
foods are needed to provide
key nutrients such as vitamin b12 and
vitamin a which are critical for brain
function
for vision
and immunity
these are found almost exclusively in
beef and and milk
all we need now is for governments to
step up
and facilitate the use of these methane
busting federatives
cattle industries
in some countries have already committed
to
climate neutrality by 2050 but
if you can get this feed additive
innovations into cow stomachs
earlier
we can cut methane burps significantly
given that methane only lasts in the
atmosphere
for a decade or so
we could even slow global warming in the
short term
about 600 million people in africa
still don't have reliable access to
electricity
and energy shortages are still a part
of daily life
african is energy
a lot
of energy
but the question is what kind
of energy in 2013
the government of my country ghana began
consultations to construct a coal plant
a 700 megawatt square plant
meant to be sighted at a configure
street a coastal fishing community in
the central region of ghana
in africa job creation and economic
opportunities are their priority
and those were the same arguments that
were made by those who were in support
of the project
they claimed that the project or the
co-plant would have created jobs for the
local youth and also expanded the
economy of the country
but we know that coal is the most
polluting form of power generation
we are also aware that from a purely
economic point of view
coal is cheap
but that is only true when we ignore the
non-economic impact of coal
ghana
and africa
need energy
but we don't want coal to be that energy
we managed to shut down the coal plants
and we didn't want code to be part of
the country's energy system our
experience shows that resistance
is possible
how
by bringing into the conversation
the address impacts and eternalities of
core plans
secondly also by providing clean
alternatives and more importantly
by involving the local communities
because they are the first to be
impacted they must also have a sea in
the conversation
in the last decade technology has moved
at a fast pace
it has lowered
its cost dramatically
africa can
and must
develop with all the energy it requires
without incurring the disastrous impact
of cold i.e health
and environmental consequences
development
and clean breathable air
must not be mutually exclusive
thank you
[Music]
thank you to forest and all of those
speakers
coming up we have more talks from the
ted countdown stage and we'll be hearing
again from vice president al gore plus
michaela j rodriguez joaquin phoenix
rooney mara performances by valerie june
and dave matthews
now david listening to excerpts from
those talks like it's clear to me what
corporations need to do what countries
need to do
but the thing that trips me up is like
what does that have to do with me like
i'm just i'm just one guy i'm just a
small fry
uh
yeah this like does anything i do matter
one way or the other like for better or
worse well first of all so all those
entities that you mentioned corporations
countries they're made up of individuals
so of course what you do as an
individual matters you may think of
yourself as a small fry but i think of
you as somebody who maybe works for a
corporation and maybe you can push that
corporation to take more climate action
or i think of you as a citizen as a
voter maybe you can vote for climate
aware candidates and push them to take
stronger climate action faster climate
action
uh you're also a member of a a community
uh a family member maybe you're a dad a
brother uh son
probably all those things
uh so
have those conversations with your
family members talk about climate change
because
that's the only way we're going to get
this done
thanks david you're making me feel
important um
if you want to find out how you can take
action ted countdown speaker johann
rockstrom who you saw earlier has
partnered with an initiative called
count us in to help us all be
part of the solution uh to find out more
go to countdown.ted.com
and
it's it does sound kind of trivial but
but one of the most important assets you
have
is your attention
like talk about what's happening talk
about it with your
family talk about it with your friends
talk about it with your
dental hygienist
circle up with and amplify folks in your
community who are working on local
solutions you could even
i don't know
host a tedx event about it
take a look
[Music]
the county of hawaii is organizing a
countdown event to inspire invoke and
encourage collective action to mitigate
the greatest challenge of our time
climate change finding better
alternatives to how we live for a safe
and health environment is not debatable
as a result i'm organizing a countdown
event in my local community
organization
[Music]
i'm organizing a countdown event for my
community because i want to help them
understand ways that they can personally
make a difference
[Music]
the person is activists
foreign
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
scientists agree it's real it's here
it's because of us but there's hope we
can change climate change join me join
me join me join me and take action today
what better world could we build
together if we told more stories about
our cooperative nature
about our deep connection to the living
world
or if we shared visions of a future not
based on hollywood dystopias devoid of
nature
but instead shared visions of a thriving
ecological civilization built on
nature's self-organizing principles
every day we tell stories
to ourselves to our friends and on our
social media platforms
what stories are you choosing to tell
are they continuing to enforce a
narrative of degeneration
or are they exciting and inspiring
others
with stories of our regeneration
i'm committed to fighting climate change
to solving the climate crisis to
changing climate change because i care
about wildlife to honor my ancestors and
to protect my kids features so i can
leave a better world for my two little
scientists at home because we have no
other choice but to fight for future
generations i am really excited for a
green future i want to see cleaner
energies electric cars yes it's all very
exciting everything on this planet
shares the same environment and we need
to protect it by rewilding natural
places we can ensure the wilderness is
preserved for generations to come this
is our time
this is our moment so i am going to do
all that i can do so the next generation
can have clean water and clean air
[Music]
people of earth thank you again for
joining us for those just tuning in this
is countdown and we're coming to you
live from the ted world theater in new
york city i'm your host latif nasser
countdown partnered with climate visuals
to hold an open call for photographs
related to climate solutions
the project received more than 5 000
submissions from over a thousand
photographers in 185 countries uh during
this next performance you'll see just
some of the eye-popping images that came
in
now here with their song astral plane is
singer songwriter valerie june
when we get into a body we concentrate
all of this light and stardust
we humans are stardust we have this
light in us and we are born to shine in
this body we come in all sizes and all
shapes and we have one job to do in this
life and like i said it is to shine and
shine fully and completely every single
day
but sometimes we forget we turn on the
news and it tells us to forget forget
forget and don't shine but i'm telling
you
so that you can remember shine
fearlessly together to protect our
planet and our future
well is there a light
that you have inside you
can't touch
a looking glass
it can only show
you
so
much
but if you follow the signs
slowly but stay heady
don't
rush
[Music]
and the day will come
when you're ready
just trust
you'll be dancing on the astral plane
and holy water cleansing rain
[Music]
fear
dancing on the astral plane and holy
water cleansing rain
floating through the stratosphere
blind beat you see so clear
dancing on the astral plane and holy
[Music]
you
is there a way
[Music]
for you to keep hearing your all
you're dreaming of dreaming
of sweetie things things great things
[Music]
dancing on the astral planet
well there is a light
that you
[Music]
don't forget
beautiful thank you valerie
the climate change mission here at
countdown it's pretty simple
break the problem down lift the
solutions up and get them out into the
real world
earlier we heard that the science is
clear
we must cut emissions in half
by 2030.
that's nine years away so
about the lifespan of a rabbit
not that long
so whether it's new solutions or the
ones we've already got we gotta hop to
it
now even if you don't fully understand
the science and i will be totally honest
i do not um most of us just have to look
outside our windows to witness firsthand
the dire consequences of climate change
don't take it from me take it from
environmentalist and america's
weatherman
al
roker ferocious tropical storms and
floods
devastating wildfires and droughts
record breaking heat waves and cold
blasts
i will tell you as somebody who has
covered
weather on television for more than 45
years we've never before witnessed such
extreme climate events and these are not
happening just in our country they are
happening all around the globe and more
frequently and more severe
scientists agree credible scientists
agree that these events are a direct
result of climate change and that
climate change is rooted in human
behavior if we as a global community
don't make the drastic changes today
kids who are born today will face a
lifetime of climate disasters just in
the last several years just in the
hurricanes that we've covered the
rapidly intensifying storms that just
seem to go on and on the wildfire
seasons that don't end it is time now
for decisive action we've got to try to
stop or at least mitigate climate change
to reduce extreme weather and most
importantly safeguard the future for our
families and our planet
for more on extreme weather let's listen
in to a conversation between david
biello and vice president al gore at the
countdown summit
what is extreme weather well the extreme
weather events we have been
experiencing in recent years are caused
in significant measure
by all the man-made global warming
pollution that we've been putting into
the thin shell of atmosphere surrounding
the planet and that global warming
pollution according to the scientists
trap
heat because the earth gets its energy
from the sun and then some of that heat
is radiated back into space and infrared
there's a natural greenhouse gas layer
that keeps temperatures within the
boundaries that are ideal for the life
that has emerged here on earth but by
thickening that
greenhouse gas layer with lots of co2
from the burning of fossil fuels and
methane and so forth it traps a lot more
heat in fact we're putting 162 million
tons of it every single day
using the sky as an open sewer and the
accumulated amount now traps as much
extra heat as would be released by 600
first generation nuclear bombs going off
every 24 hours that's a lot of heat and
what that does is disrupt the water
cycle the wind patterns are different
the ocean currents
are
now being pushed in toward new patterns
and since weather is the result of
climate patterns that have emerged over
a long period of time when the climate
pattern is pushed out of its familiar
shape then the extreme weather events
occur so dry areas get drier wet areas
get wetter and you just get
so much more water in a shorter period
of time yes the the the extra heat
that's trapped in the earth system uh
evaporates a lot more water vapor off
the oceans this feeds atmospheric rivers
that on average have as much water as 25
mississippi rivers and when they
reach storm conditions that trigger a
downpour you get a
a rain bomb as some people call them and
in some cases kind of an airborne
tsunami and you get enormous amounts of
rain also snow if the conditions
are cold enough and that same heat also
pulls the moisture out of the first
meter of soil so that the droughts take
hold more quickly and last
longer so you get both more droughts and
more floods and mudslides anywhere you
look all around the world the extreme
weather is happening can we expect more
of this in future is it going to get
worse what happens next well the
scientists have warned us that as bad as
these extreme weather events are now
they're nothing compared to what we
could experience in the future if we
don't stop using the sky as an open
sewer for all this heat trapping
pollution
so what gives you hope that we will do
that well the the hope i feel uh is
based in part on the amazing progress
that scientists and technologists
have made in developing alternatives to
the burning of fossil fuel
electric vehicles in place of internal
combustion engines regenerative
agriculture that puts more co2 back into
the soil and
the vegetation sustainable forestry to
protect the forest areas protection of
the oceans
we have seen the solutions emerge almost
like the development of vaccines in
record time we've seen science and
technology give us solutions for the
climate crisis in record time but just
as with the vaccines we've got to deploy
them and we've gotten to we've got to
straighten out our political
dysfunctions in order to spread to
deploy them all around the world we are
one world ecologically in terms of the
pandemic threat certainly in terms of
the climate crisis and and we have to
deploy these solutions worldwide well
thank you for joining us former vice
president al gore thank you
a big countdown thank you to vice
president al gore for shouting this
issue out from the rooftops for decades
and a smaller countdown thank you to the
fieldgate plaza mall near where i grew
up for selling me a bootleg copy of his
groundbreaking documentary labeled an
inconvenient truth
that's not a joke that's simply the
inconvenient truth okay let's get to
some of the people's questions for you
uh david we actually had a lot of great
ones about uh electric car batteries
oceans the impact of climate change on
health we'll cover those don't worry in
talks coming up uh but here let's just
start with the first one i got right
here for you
1.5
versus 2 degrees celsius doesn't really
sound like a big deal um like and i can
relate like
on my thermostat at home there's not
even an option for half degrees uh why
does a half degree matter that is a
great question thank you so one way to
think about that is to roll it back
if you went
roughly that same amount of temperature
down for global average temperatures we
would be back in an ice age so that's
the difference between
the earth covered in ice and the earth
we live on right now so roll it forward
and we've only gone about a degree
celsius so far and we're already seeing
more fires more floods more droughts
extreme weather like you just heard
about we gotta stop
every tenth of a degree matters and
that's why the difference between one
point five and two is so important it's
not like we fall off a cliff at two i
mean i want to be real
but 2.1 is infinitely better than three
and so on and so forth right and it's
and it's an average too i think right
exactly exactly yeah okay uh
another question for you and this makes
sense because it's people are talking
from their wallets uh energy prices are
rising around the world some people
blame
renewable energy sources like solar and
wind
is that true
it is not spoiler alert
so uh the the short answer to that is
it's the reverse it's actually fossil
fuels that are causing the instability
in energy prices you don't have to pay
for sunshine you do have to pay for coal
oil and natural gas because somebody dug
it up
and what's happening let's take the
example of the eu where they are having
an energy crisis why are they having an
energy crisis it's not because they
built all those windmills or put in all
those solar panels and all the other
things they've done it's because they're
reliant on russian gas and you got to
pay for russian gas
that's it
all right if you have more questions for
david tweet us using the hashtag
tedcountdown or put them in the chat
below uh now let's welcome an actor
singer activist who is a member of
climate power's creative council
advisory board uh here to introduce more
ideas from ted countdown stages michaela
j rodriguez
hi i'm michaela j rodriguez
food
water air these are the bare minimums we
need to survive
and they're all provided by the amazing
beautiful planet we call home
but we're destroying it
i actually remember the first time i saw
my first natural disaster and not only
was i worried
and scared
but i was driven to action
we may not be able to reverse all the
damage we've caused but we can stop
adding to the problem by protecting the
invaluable resources we have left
we have the ability to transform our
wild spaces within the next 10 years
allowing nature to help us clean up our
mess and in turn save millions of lives
we must save the natural world to save
ourselves and these next ted countdown
speakers are here to tell us how
[Music]
today globally
only seven percent of the ocean
and less than a fifth of our land have
been protected
that means that we have converted most
of our planet into a tame environment
where 96 of the mass of the mammals is
us
in our domesticated livestock
only four percent is everything else
from pandas to tigers to elephants
and we have removed over 90 percent of
the large fish in the ocean in the last
century alone
on top of the loss of nature we have
global warming
this summer of 2021 has seen some of the
hottest temperatures in human history
in places that one would expect to be
cool
like canada finland and siberia
this extreme heat kills hundreds of
thousands of people
and fuels raging wildfires turning towns
forests and grasslands into ashes
also killing billions
of individual animals and trees
and many coral reefs
around the world
no place is safe anymore
unless we re-wild our planet
if we are to prevent a global disaster
we need to do two things
as we know we need to reduce emissions
of greenhouse gases to almost zero
but we also need to draw down the excess
carbon pollution in the atmosphere and
in the ocean
that's why in 2018 i put together a team
of top scientists and economists to
answer the question of which areas in
the ocean we must protect first and how
much of the ocean do we need to protect
to solve that problem
we developed a new framework to optimize
multiple benefits
picking which areas to protect depends
on how much we value the different
objectives
we found that if we gain the same weight
to each biodiversity food and carbon
we would want to protect the right 45
percent of the ocean to maximize the
three benefits
we also found that even if we didn't
value biodiversity
the minimum amount of ocean we would
protect would be 30 percent
so 30 of the ocean is the floor
the minimum area that we need to protect
if we want to preserve marine life and
all the benefits it provides for people
similar analysis have been done for the
land
also showing 30
as a minimum
armed with this research we are national
geographic partnered with the whis
campaign for nature and launched a
campaign for 30 by 30
meaning at least 30 percent of the
planet
land and sea
protected by 2030.
working with the governments of costa
rica france and the united kingdom we
built a high ambition coalition for
nature and people
which now has 66 countries in it and
growing
all supporting 30 by 30 as a main target
for a global deal on nature
30 of our planet by 2030.
only that amount of wild nature
together with a massive reduction in
carbon emissions will be able to get us
back on track
[Music]
what we do know is that the ocean is a
vital part of our life support system on
the planet
it produces at least 50 of the oxygen
that we breathe so more than one in
every two breaths
it also regulates temperature for the
planet so without the ocean the poles
would be unbearably cold and the equator
would be unbearably hot and it would be
a lot harder to live here
now we think about saving the ocean from
plastic or from oil and oil spills or
from overfishing but really
we should be thinking about how the
ocean is saving us
and what is it saving us from
it's saving us from the climate change
that we are creating essentially
ourselves
and yet when we think about climate
action and climate strategies and
climate plans
we often overlook the ocean and leave it
out
because somehow we think that saving the
ocean is something else we have to do
not a core part of our climate strategy
and that's what has to change
because the ocean is a core part of our
climate system and so it has to be a
core part of our climate solutions
the climate crisis is a health crisis
it threatens our air water food shelter
security all the basics on which the
human life depends
burning of fossil fuels for electricity
heat or transport is a major driver for
climate change and a main contributor to
air
pollution globally air pollution causes
7 million premature deaths each year
that's 13 deaths every minute
way more than the death toll of covet by
the end of summer of 2021
and the poor and the marginalized are
more severely impacted
time has come
that we measure the advancement of our
civilization through the metric of
health rather than metric of wealth
but here also
[Applause]
but here also lies one of our biggest
roadblocks
it is impossible to have healthy people
on a sick planet
[Music]
if i stop breathing for two minutes
i will die
it is the simplest thing
that all of us do unconsciously about
twenty thousand times a day
so normal
that we forget that breathing is the
essence of life
my daughter ella roberta
stop breathing frequently
and was resuscitated numerous times
by me at home
and in hospital
by her doctors
until suddenly
on the 15th of february
three weeks after her ninth birthday
she took her final breath
a second inquest into ella's death
just in december 2020 the coroner philip
barlow
he concluded that it was the excessive
illegal levels of air pollution
not only inducted her asthma
but it was the highest ever on the night
she died
as a result of this ella is the first
person
in the world to have air pollution
listed as the cause of death
on her death certificate
and the story is unique i admit
but her experience is shockingly
ordinary
in too many countries around the world
air pollution exceeds
what the who tells us is acceptable to
breathe
fossil fuels
everyone
they're killing us
almost one in five premature deaths are
linked to air pollution
from combustion engines
co-power plants wood burning
ammonia cooking stoves and other fossil
fuels
that is 8.7 million people
a year dying from heart attacks cancer
strokes dementia suicide depression
still births
and miscarriages
and that's just the start
children are the worst affected
due to their lungs still developing
air pollution stuns the development
of lungs and brains
scientists believe it are finding soot
in mother's placentas meaning unborn
babies are directly exposed to the black
carbon
produced by motor traffic and fuel
burning
like ella
93 of children around the world are
breathing unsafe air
the real tragedy of this
is we know how to solve this public
health crisis we need to shift from
toxic fossil fuels to clean electrified
public and active transport
[Applause]
the second inquest into ella's death
made it abundantly clear
ella would still be here alive today if
air pollution around our home had been
within the who acceptable limits
air pollution
is an invisible global pandemic
choking smoke polluted waters
climate change this has been the
environmental cost of the tremendous
growth in china over the past 40 years
at the same time hundreds of millions of
people have put themselves out of
poverty
as an environmentalist in china i have
witnessed all of this
firsthand the challenge we're facing is
can we clean up as fast and as broadly
as the massive development degrading our
air water and climate the pressing
global climate situation requires each
of us not just to do it but to do it
faster
i believe there's a chance for us to
succeed as i know it too that i've seen
work to help reduce the enormous
environmental pollution
it is the power of transparency
pollution information made public using
mobile internet and other i.t
technologies
many empowers millions of citizens to
speed change by holding corporations and
government agencies accountable
my team and i have launched a blue map
for zero carbon a database that means to
bring china's long-term national
commitment down to where
the 10 billion tons of carbon are
actually emitted
this is how a
zero carbon map looks like each province
and city is color-coded based on its
level of emission and it's not
just carbon
today we further expand the blue map to
cover
wisdom plastics and even biodiversity so
as to empower more people
to join this unprecedented
global race to zero
the price for winning this ongoing race
is nothing less than a better word for
this generation
and for the generations to come
for mankind
and for all the plants
and animals
that call this planet
their home
[Music]
thank you to michaela j and those ted
countdown speakers for showing us that
we have to protect nature to protect
ourselves
now here's another powerful champion for
the environment and a u.n goodwill
ambassador since 2005 he and his band
have eliminated over 120 million pounds
of co2 and half a million single-use
plastic bottles from their shows
here with the performance he recorded
especially for countdown
is dave matthews
hello uh i'm dave matthews and i was
invited to play a song
thank you for having me i was also
invited to say
something
about climate change although i'm
confident that those who are qualified
have already
said all that needs to be said
but it does seem to be by far the
biggest problem
facing humanity facing the world
and
and we certainly have to do something
about it we have to do everything about
it it should be everything we think
about
and then i also think about the fact
that if every fish
and every bird and every flower and
every tree and every human and every
little critter
if all of it vanished
and left a dead
planet that was once once
beautiful and blue
it wouldn't
not even the moon would notice
the stars certainly wouldn't miss us
just be a speck of dust that never was
and
maybe that's a comfort
this song's called dive in and i hope
it's appropriate
[Music]
i saw a man on the side of the road with
a sign that red
i will work for food
so i tried to look busy
until the light turned green
and i saw a bear on tv
cause his friends were all drowning
see their homes were turning to water
a strange kind of sad big old bear
i'm sorry would happily eat me
he could tear me
wake up
sleepyhead i think the sun's a little
brighter today smile and watch the
icicles melt away
see the water rise and summers here to
stay and that sweet summer breeze will
blow forever go down to the shore kick
off your shoes dive in the empty ocean
you tell me
everything will be
okay if i just stay on my knees and keep
praying
believing in something
you tell me
everything is all taken care of by those
qualified to take care of it all
[Music]
and take care of it
some wake up
sleepy head i think the sun's a little
brighter today smiling watch the icicles
melt away
see the water rise in summers here to
stay and all those summer games will
last forever go down to the shore kick
off issues dive in the empty ocean
[Music]
someday
you think we'll wake up
in a world
on its way to getting better and if so
can you tell me
have been thinking
that lately
the blood is increasing
the tourniquet's not keeping hold
in spite of our twisting
though we would love to believe that we
are we are not in control
though we would love to believe
[Music]
a little brighter today smile and watch
the icicles melt away
see the waters rise in the summers in a
stand all those summer girls will dance
forever go down to the shore kick off
your shoes dive in the empty ocean
thank you for having me
wow that guy's pretty good
real up-and-comer
all right uh earlier rayne wilson asked
his friends if there's anything funny
about climate change
let's check back in with them
knock knock knock knock knock knock
who's there
nobody
cause you're all dead
is a global warming
who's there
uh dinosaurs
dinosaurs who exactly
they gone you know we could be like the
dinosaurs we could be gone like that
right
that's what i'm talking about come on
that's funny you guys knock knock
who's this
climate
change climate change who
climate change is largely a man-made
phenomenon which the scientific
community at large
agrees will wreak
almost inconceivable death and
destruction on our planet
unless there is immediate and
significant societal change
get it
a polar bear ghost walks into a bar and
the bartender says hey get out of here
we don't serve polar bears in here and
the polar bear ghost says oh don't worry
i'm not real because of global warming
we're all extinct and the bartender was
like i apologize for the initial
hostility but you gotta admit kind of
hard to tell the difference between a
polar bear and a polar bear ghost
[Music]
do you get it because they're both white
it's it never mind sorry
penguins
it's a flightless bird how are they not
all dead anyway
um
second
something funny about climate change
[Music]
rain's gonna keep working on that and
we'll check back in with him later
now one of the most heartening things
about the last few years has been the
way that
millions of young people have basically
muscled the climate crisis to the top of
the global agenda their
clarity their persistence their moral
authority is
unignorable
two of them took the countdown stage in
scotland two weeks ago here's what they
said
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is shia bastida
and my name is shiv sohan and we are a
youth of youth climate activists who
have been present throughout countdown
and yesterday we came together to put
together a list of demands that we have
for leaders of the world
we are asking leaders around the world
to take the following action one divest
from all fossil fuel investments and
reinvest in green energy and ensure a
just transition led by workers and
impacted communities
two
center climate justice in all key policy
decisions including protection for
frontline communities from pollution as
well as from climate disasters three
stop all open pipelines and oil and
fossil fuel extraction initiatives from
line three in the united states to cambo
right here in scotland to e-cop in
uganda
and all over the world
four
hold lark corporations accountable for
their actions that contribute directly
to the climate crisis this includes
paying taxes having youth a
decision-making tables and
last but not least ensuring a just
transition to renewable energy five
create policies to protect activists
rights to peaceful protest and safeguard
democracy all across the world
six
remove the economic political and social
influence of fossil fuel companies from
key international decision making spaces
to be clear these listed demands are not
exhaustive in what we need to solve the
climate crisis this is the bare minimum
we find ourselves in a critical moment
where we don't have the time to lose on
just talking and having conferences that
won't amount to real action
never before have we had
a moment that is rooted in science and
experience felt so deeply among all of
us so join the youth in leading
joining us today thank you
[Applause]
are here with me now shii uh you made
this point about how this moment is kind
of the
it's a combo of science and experience
what did what did you mean by that
what i mean by that is that we have
known about the climate crisis in
scientific terms for you know the past
30 years but until now we hadn't really
experienced the climate crisis and now
we have that in in our memory as youth
you know my hometown suffered from from
flooding in 2015 in mexico and my
roommate in college told me like she had
to be on the phone with her parents uh
talking to them about how to get out of
new orleans because of ida so
now we as the new generation are feeling
the effects of the climate crisis and
especially in you know marginalized
communities frontline communities and
the global south so now that is why it's
so important for youth to be at this
decision-making places because we bring
those stories and that narrative is what
switches people's perspectives not just
data but stories tied to that data yeah
and and shiv can you like
lay out for me like what what vision do
you have of the future what do you think
is is possible yeah and that's what we
were doing at countdown we met with a
lot of youth activists across the world
and we came up with this list of demands
because as young people we have the
clarity to see exactly what needs to be
done what needs to now happen is world
leaders need to listen we need leaders
of companies to actually take the action
of divestment reinvestment and also move
our global economy to zero fossil fuels
to renewable energy because the way that
we're going right now is not sustainable
for our generation for the generations
here right now and for generations to
come we have so much work to do and
that's how we have to get moving now
yeah so you were on that stage now
you're on this stage there's a there's
there's a big audience out there who i
think a lot of them are probably
wondering like how do i get involved in
the movement what do you want to say to
them yeah well just to start out shia
and i started working together a few
years ago right here in new york city
and the way you can get involved is just
by starting in your community and see
what actually needs to be done whether
that's starting conversations with your
family doing something in your school
your local city council your local state
government anything like that any small
action where you're actually making your
voice heard and really holding those who
have power to account that is what's
going to make the change
yeah and for glasgow for cop 26 that i'm
headed to right after this you're about
to your bags are packed right over there
right pax
we are actually organizing a global
climate strike on november 5th so
wherever you are in the world you can
join this global climate strike on
friday and then on november 6th
the cop26 coalition is also organizing a
mobilization so for people who can't
make it on the 5th they can make it on
the 6th and that direct action of going
out into the streets not only shows
governments and companies that we are
serious about change but they also show
them that you know people together
cannot be defeated and it empowers us to
be part of this movement
wow thank you so much shiv and uh
now to guide us through another batch of
ted countdown talks are two actors who
deserve as many accolades for their
activism as they receive for their work
on screen
joaquin phoenix and rooney mara
we are in a true planetary emergency
and most people don't know that the
number one contributing factor to
increasing global temperatures is the
way that we fuel our homes
our businesses our modes of
transportation and our bodies
now we are going to have to transform
all of these systems in a massive way
and soon
all that can feel very overwhelming
but for us
being vegan is a privileged choice that
we get to make every day multiple times
a day that we know will make a huge
impact there are so many decisions that
are made that are outside of our control
that affect our lives and the planet but
this is one thing that we do have
control over that we know will make a
difference
you
if any of us are going to claim to truly
care about the planet
then we can no longer ignore
the role animal agriculture is playing
in destroying it
this challenge actually presents an
immense opportunity for innovation we
are witnessing some truly incredible
leadership in this fight for our planet
let's hear from these ted countdown
speakers about both the giant scale of
change that is needed
and some of the ways in which industries
are transforming to meet our climate
goals
thank you
[Music]
today the world generates about 25
trillion kilowatt hours of electricity
each year
most of that is from fossil fuel power
plants and the dominant mindset is that
we have to change the current
electricity system by replacing those
fossil fuel plants with clean generation
so this is great we can replace all our
fossil fuel plants have a clean version
of today's world walk away we've solved
climate change thank you very much
oh
but i did forget one tiny little detail
we actually need five times that much
to be clear we need and we're on track
to have two and a half times today's
amount of clean generation to switch to
a clean version of our current
electricity system
but changing the current system isn't
enough
we need five times that all of it clean
or 12 times today's clean electricity
production to actually avoid the worst
impacts of climate change
our project is not changing the current
global electricity system
our project is building a new global
electricity system
political action that tinkers around
within the current system will never get
us where we need to be by 2050.
arguments over which sources of clean
electricity we should use are unhelpful
we need all of them hydro solar wind
nuclear advanced nuclear advanced
geothermal mandates for carbon capture
on remaining fossil plants if you look
at the potential rates of addition for
each of these you'll see we need
everything as much as possible and we
may still fall short
it's not changing the electricity system
it's building a new electricity system
one five times bigger than today's total
system and a hundred percent clean this
mindset goes beyond electricity
generation itself many people are wary
of ambitious climate action because they
see the project as changing the familiar
current world
that's not it
addressing climate change means building
a new world
a world in which energy is healthier
doesn't pollute the air we breathe and
where it's cheaper and everyone globally
has access to it
a world with higher incomes longer and
better lives greater equality
a better world
[Applause]
now when you think of the industries
most responsible for climate change you
probably summon up an image of an oil
rig right
maybe even a coal mine or a mega farm
perhaps heavy engineering
but there's one industry that's never
mentioned in that list
even though every other industry depends
upon it
i'm talking about an economic sector
that makes
nothing
it has no stock
no no warehouses no factories
it's entirely powered by brains
by spreadsheets and by powerpoint
who is this mystery industry
the professional services
of advertising and pr firms the big
management consultancies the corporate
lawyers and lobbyists
together this sector is worth over two
trillion dollars a year
let's call it the x industry
where x is for influence
the brain print of the x industry is
felt everywhere
and that's because these problem solvers
and storytellers act as the greece in
the wheel of all other businesses on
earth
and that gives the x industry an
outsized influence on the likelihood
that we reach net zero
or they will be one of the primary
architects of climate destruction
[Music]
more than nine percent of co2 emissions
globally come from transporting goods
around the world
so what is the
dream in 2018 the management team of ap
miller mask
the global shipping company i lead as a
chairman
made a commitment to make the company
carbon neutral by 2050.
some people 2050 sounded like a long
time into the future but in fact this
was a very ambitious dream for a
shipping company
to be carbon neutral by 2050 we needed
to invent a zero carbon container vessel
by 2030
because then it would take roughly 20
years to replace all of the 750 vessels
that we operate
so the dream was truly big
and really inspiring
but to be honest
in 2018
we did not know how to do this
we had to work hard on the details
less than three years after our big
dream
we have found a solution
it is called power2x
now power2x is not a new technology nor
did we invent it it is a combination of
known chemical processes to convert
green electricity
to a green fuel
first you convert the green electricity
from solar or wind to green hydrogen
that is done through electrolysis
and then the green hydrogen can be
converted to various types of green
fuels through chemical processes
the benefit of power 2x is that it
produces a green fuel that is liquid at
normal temperature and can be used in a
combustion engine
so instead of spending 20 years to
replace all of our 750 vessels
and create a big pile of waste
we believe we can retrofit existing
vessels by adding a combustion engine
designed for green fuel
and with that achieve zero carbon
shipping much much earlier
today among investors there are a lot of
questions about decarbonizing portfolios
and how to achieve net zero
but when i think about the intersection
of climate and capital
i'm always asking myself
what effect is this really having on the
ground
because
there could be a profound difference
between investing just to protect your
assets from the effects of climate
change
and actually investing to prevent those
effects from coming about
because what the world really needs is
real decarbonization
we need to decarbonize the old economy
that we have and invest to create the
new economy that we need
it needs to be an economy that emits
no more than it can remove
and that does this in a way that is net
positive for the planet and the people
[Applause]
estimates suggest
that it will cost three to five trillion
dollars a year between now and 2050
to achieve net zero
just to give you an idea of how much
that is it would be like investing the
entire gdp of germany or japan
every year
annually for 30 years
so
financial capital has a huge role to
play in our shared success or our shared
failure
by 2100 the world will have a population
of almost 11 billion people
that is three billion more people than
the planet houses today
to house all of those people
we need to build
about
2.4 trillion
square feet of new built space
we are already experiencing
severe
impacts from climate change how can the
world house another three billion people
and how can their housing needs be part
of the solution rather than part of the
problem
i believe that the answer is hiding in
plain sight that there is what i call a
goldilocks scale
that sits between the scale of housing
and towers
two to three story housing
that should actually look very familiar
to most of you because we built the most
beloved parts of our cities with it
the row houses of boston the hutong
districts of beijing
most of the fabric of edinburgh
this goldilocks framework
hits the sweet spot between the number
of people it can house
and the amount of roof area we need to
provide them and their communities power
it can be built out of simple local
materials
like wood
or brick
both of which have relatively low
embodied energy and can be built by
local workers
and the solar panels up above could be
supplemented with state-of-the-art
battery systems that level out solar
supply and user demand we can have
electric state-of-the-art air
conditioning and heating systems this
exists today
this housing could compost
food scraps and solid waste and turn it
into
usable soils or protein for animal feed
and i think most importantly this kind
of housing can provide
affordable communal equitable housing
for communities in dire need of it and i
work with a lot of these communities and
i know how much demand there is for this
out there
i want you now imagine with me that we
deployed this goldilocks framework in
two places that i love dearly new york
and calcutta very different places but
they have these big booming downtowns
but they also have these growing
outskirts that experience a lot of
sprawl so they have sites like this that
are near mass transit but imagine if on
these sites we instead of building
sprawl
built this goldilocks framework now that
would manifest in two very very
different ways different materials
different cultural expressions but it
would give us carbon negative
transit-rich
joyous
places for people to live and raise
their families
so yes
we can go to 11
11 billion people
we don't need to fear our neighbors
we don't have a lack of land or
technology
we just have a lack of vision because
the answers are hiding in plain sight
thank you very much
meat-eating is linked to climate change
eating animals and animal agriculture is
the leading cause of rainforest
deforestation
meat production is the significant
source of greenhouse gas emissions there
are so many reasons to eat plant-based
and any reason that resonates with you
is the best reason i understand it's not
always easy
but eating even one plant-based meal a
day makes a huge difference
i used to be a long-time meat-eater as a
regular chef
i used to cook lots of meat and never
made that connection that they are
living beings just like us with feelings
emotions and families
i'm now on a mission to unleash the
mighty power of plants to create foods
that we crave
full of flavors and textures that are
more nutritious and better for us and
the planet
i believe in compassionate action
and the way i express that is through
cooking and developing amazing recipes
that inspire and teach people how to
make and eat delicious foods without
animals
vegan food for meat eaters and vegans
alike because like most people i want to
save the animals and the planet
there's no way that's going to happen if
i have to compromise on taste
[Music]
we're living in a decisive decade
one that years from now your kids their
kids even just random kids down the
street are gonna ask you about it
what did you do
how are you involved in one of if not
the biggest story on the planet
did it have anything to do with a live
stream you watched hosted by a certain
lanky over eager podcaster you're gonna
want to have something to tell those
kids get involved take action one way to
do it head to countdown.ted.com
still to come regina hall presents more
inspiring ted countdown talks plus conan
o'brien aisha tyler and margaret cho
weigh in on whether climate change can
be funny
and we've got another performance by
charlie puth
up now ted countdown speaker monica
araya is here to tell us about an
exciting project called drive electric
it's raised over half a billion billion
with a b
dollars to do this work you can learn
more at
drivetheelectriccampaign.org or by
listening to this from monica
hello my name is monica araga and i'm a
campaigner at drive electric so if you
think about it right now around the
planet there are around 1 billion cars
circulating everywhere and that is not
even counting buses trucks motorbikes
and only one percent of that stock
is zero emission only one percent is
electric so our campaign is about making
sure that we electrify
everything we can trucks buses cars
fleets and of course we need fewer cars
so in essence we're trying to go much
faster and the next
five years are critical our campaign
basically brings together 70
groups around the planet and this
coalition is growing we're fundraising 1
billion dollars because we need to make
sure that all these activists all these
organizations have funding some will
work with cities some will work with
politicians some will work with
companies we have to normalize
the idea
that after a certain date
we cannot sell any more petrol and
diesel cars
we are saying
no more sales of dirty buses after 2030
of zero emission
cars by 2035
for passenger cars and vans and then
when it comes to trucks we have to give
them a little bit of more time because
the technology is still expensive and we
are saying 20 40. there are many
misconceptions and and to some degree
that's normal one that comes
often in the conversation is that
if you switch to an electric car that is
going to be worse for the environment
because of the batteries
and we have
lots of research that shows
that if you have a life cycle analysis
of the battery it will have an impact
for sure everything we produce has an
impact and yet the impact the
environmental impact of a fossil fuel
car is way bigger i would say that the
one that worries me the most
is the perception that electric mobility
is an elite agenda for people with a lot
of money and that is probably happening
because people link
e-mobility with a tesla which is you
know a premium car and
to some degree is understandable and yet
i would really like
us
to think about the drivers
the drivers of a public bus
the driver of a truck
the driver of a taxi that has to every
day
get all that pollution in their lungs
all that noise is always there
and when you talk to them they will tell
you they will never go back
to the polluting technology
at the same time we know that for
example diesel truck pollution
hurts
vulnerable communities you know
low-income neighborhoods the most it
hurts everybody but it hurts
the poor disproportionate
so
working on electrification is also a
matter of justice it's also a matter of
increasing
air quality improving air quality and to
the extent we link those two agendas
climate and justice we will realize that
electrification is actually
very good for for people
[Music]
hey everybody i am committed to changing
climate change because i love our planet
i think it's beautiful and i think it's
just unfortunate that i haven't seen a
lot of it i've seen a tiny tiny bit of
it and i want to explore it and i want
the coming generations to see it and see
what a beautiful place we are born on
but i love our planet and i will do
everything that i can every day to make
sure that we change climate change so
join me and take action today
i'm mitch and i'm greg and we are asap
science we are committed to fighting
climate change because we are viscerally
experiencing it ourselves we're from
canada specifically ontario and this
past summer there were horrible
wildfires that were really surprising
for us we'd never really seen them
before and it's just ontario is where we
live and it's a beautiful part of the
world that i've never thought this would
happen in and i'm just honestly kind of
scared and i think also we are
viscerally aware that we are privileged
people from a privileged country that's
disproportionately affecting the climate
crisis so it's our responsibility to
take that on ourselves we're also
science communicators we read science
all the time we're science teachers and
science and the climate crisis are
completely linked because we're using
scientific evidence to understand what's
going on but we're also using science to
figure out the solutions
[Music]
once again people of earth grateful for
your attention thank you for coming i'm
latif nasser this is countdown welcome
to those of you who are just joining us
from wherever in the world you may be we
are coming to you
live from the ted world theater in new
york city talking about solutions to the
climate crisis and
a lot of today's speakers have outlined
a realistic pathway towards a cleaner
more just future
here to introduce more ideas from the
ted countdown stage is actor and
activist regina hall
hello i'm regina hall humans across the
globe have so much in common we often
share the same goals health security
happiness opportunity prosperity
if we are serious about expanding access
to all of these for more people we must
address the climate crisis immediately
the most severe impacts of this crisis
are felt
first and hardest by the poor and
vulnerable
ironically those who have often done
the least to cause it
we must act together
near and far across the oceans and
within our communities
we are only as strong as the most
exposed among us i come to this topic
via my work on women's health and rights
i know that the way we treat our planet
is equally important to the way that we
treat our bodies
and sadly
women often get the short end of the
stick
it's time to change this once and for
all
but how do we do that
we can start by
by listening to voices from around the
world
including and especially those young
people
leading the way for future generations
leadership comes in all shapes and sizes
and the best leaders inspire others to
step up to
as we've witnessed during our current
global pandemic we all have to play our
part to overcome it
the same is true about the climate
crisis
so here are some great leaders from
around the globe
maybe they will bring out the leader in
me and the leader in all of you
[Music]
wow
today many of us are getting involved at
a younger and younger age 16 year olds
15 14 10 year olds are out on the front
lines
missing school drafting manifestos
organizing demonstrations bringing
governments and corporations to court
refusing to wait until we are older to
start making a difference
but being a change maker
is not something anybody has on their
bucket list it isn't something kids
aspire to become when they grow up
it's something that just happens
something activates you
an experience an injustice that takes
place
big or small
local or global and then there is almost
no choice but to get involved
in the last few years i have spent more
time in other students classrooms than
in my own sharing principles of
leadership sustainability and change
maker skills
and i can say with confidence that young
people
are aching for skills and knowledge that
will allow them to act effectively today
real change can start in the classroom
but the classroom has an increasingly
distant relationship with reality
i think it is high time to ensure that
what we learn in the classrooms reflect
what is happening outside of them
and to ensure that every single student
in every corner of the world has at
least one hour a day of mandatory
lessons about the climate crisis the 17
sdgs and about any sustainable
innovations about the realities of
today's world from kindergarten through
to graduation and i mean mandatory i
strongly believe
that every young person can be a change
maker but often they need help knowing
where and how to start
[Music]
at just 12 years old
i witnessed the devastating impact
pollution was having on iran
my parents home country
on one of my summer visits i witnessed
smog so heavy it completely blanketed
the air
obscuring the stars i wanted to trace
out of the night sky
i decided to read more about climate
change in iran and i became increasingly
alarmed
particularly when i learned the fact
that temperatures in the middle east
were rising more than twice the global
average
armed with this knowledge i decided to
confront my relatives
but i was shocked when they informed me
that they knew almost nothing about
climate change
so i began to dig into the lack of
climate education in iran
and i found a study that read only five
percent of iranian students could
properly explain the greenhouse gas
effect
as i continued to scour the internet for
more information
i began to connect the dots
from what i could see there was a severe
lack of climate resources available in
farsi
iran's native language
now
my story is anecdotal
but the fact that the vast majority of
scientific research is only available in
english is a big problem when it comes
to climate change
because most people in the world
don't speak english
in fact
75 percent of them do not speak english
at all
in an effort to close the climate
translation gap
i decided to start climate cardinals
an international youth-led non-profit
working to make climate education more
accessible to those who don't speak
english
we work with over eight thousand
bilingual student volunteers who
translate climate information in
exchange for community service hours
in just over a year we've translated
hundreds of thousands of words of
climate information into over 100
languages
including yerba somali swahili and
gujarati
if a ragtag group of teenagers that
congregate through social media can do
this work
imagine the impact that a concentrated
effort by governments scientists and
policy makers would have
groups of people that are being
disproportionately affected by climate
change deserve to have access to the
resources they need to make sense of
these disasters that are destroying
their communities
the more people are informed about the
climate crisis the greater chance we
have to coordinate collective efforts in
protection of the future of our planet
because every single person in the world
every single person in this room
has the power to further climate action
so we must engage people
from every country
young and old
to join the fight for climate justice
english
cannot be the barrier to entry
mitsumini
sumini is the leader of indonesia's
first woman light ranger team and a
mother
a conservationist whose action is rooted
in her community on the edge of the
loyster ecosystem
in the patriarchal society where she
operates
a woman is expected to be quiet and
subservient
during a village meeting the ladies tend
to congregate in the kitchen while the
men discuss village policies and budget
and oftentimes even if she is present in
a meeting room she is expected to not
voice her opinion
rather letting a male relative to answer
questions addressed to her
without consulting her first
when i asked sumini why
she chose to protect and conserve the
forest
she said
we are mothers and grandmothers
we are responsible for everything
from the moment we wake up we have to
wash clothes
cook and make coffee for our family
more than anything we need water in
every aspect of our life and the only
thing that protect our water source
is the forest up the mountain
the path for sumini to lead these
rangers is anything but straightforward
she became familiar with the forest when
she began accompanying her husband
trekking
during these trips they witnessed
encroachment and logging
they saw people taking out timber and
encroaching into the
forest logging and encroachment that
happened upstream
soon turned into disasters downstream
a heavy rainfall that lasted for a few
days turned into flash floods and
landslides
destroying the village and its essential
infrastructure
after the disaster sumini and other
villagers had to take refuge in a
shelter for a while
being a refugee is
hard you don't have privacy and security
you don't even have the access to clean
flowing water
it's hard to even keep yourself
safe and clean
i don't want that kind of disaster to
happen again she said to me
we need more women in the position of
leadership
women from the grassroots
women like sumini
nosotros
um
why is it
so hard
to change the direction of our
civilization
i'd like to suggest that what's missing
at this point is not more facts and
information or even technology
we have more than enough
what's missing is insight
my teacher zen master tiknit han
has said that if we haven't yet
changed our way of living
it's because the awakening isn't strong
enough
we can't hope to change the world if we
can't change our own way of seeing
things our consciousness
but how can we do this
in the zen tradition we know that
awakening
doesn't happen
only with the intellect
we need to engage our whole being
right in the heart of the present moment
and a very simple way to do this
is with the practice of mindful
walking
a powerful meditation that doesn't
require hard labor or even extra time
do you remember the first steps you took
outside this morning
the feel of the ground
underfoot
the fall of the light
the
quality of the air
do you remember the first
tree
on your way
life is there for us but the question is
are we there for life
perhaps this morning we had something
more important to do
perhaps we were in a hurry
many of us have a feeling that we are
running
out of time
but when we rush to do something
are we saving
time or are we losing it
there is a lot that is urgent
but in order to take the kind of radical
decisive action that our planet is
calling for
we need to be fully present
grounded and alert
fearless and free
[Music]
there are notable powerful stories of
leadership out there at at all levels
from small communities to the global
stage and one lesson i take from the
stories we've heard today
is that it can be hard really really
hard to have hope in the face of a
challenge this big but
we just have to choose optimism
and we just gotta show up for each other
we'll be seeing more environmental
leaders at a very important event that
starts tomorrow it's called cop26 and
we've invited some experts and friends
of countdown to tell us all about it
cop26 the conference of the parties on
the climate treaty
is where every nation in the world comes
together to negotiate collective action
to solve the climate crisis cop 26 which
is the one that is coming up now
in glasgow is the 26th time that these
governments are getting together to do
frankly follow up to the paris agreement
they need to come to the table
to report to each other what they have
done since paris and most importantly
commit to each other what further
efforts they're going to do over the
next five to 10 years the most decisive
decade in the history of humanity well
the first thing we're cop 26 that the
average viewer should find out there's a
lot of acronyms so unfortunately there's
one right now the ipcc intergovernmental
panel on climate change did a report
that said that we had 12 years and that
was
three and a half years ago and cop26 is
also a crop that has been affected i
would say positively by the late the
last two
ipcc reports signs spoke very loudly uh
in october 2018 with the ipcc report of
1.5 degrees and just a few months
from from today we received this sixth
report uh in august that was named as a
red code for humanity those two reports
are allowing us to understand the
importance of following science and the
big risk that we have in front of us if
we don't follow the science as indicated
in those reports the commitments that
are going to be made at cop26 are
critically important because they will
tell us whether we're on track
to the goal that has to be reached by
2030 which is cutting global emissions
from where they are today to 50
the language is
not everyday language and it is the
job of us as activists to be
communicators of the science and
of the decisions that happen behind
these walls the involvement of youth is
really important because we bring the
element of urgency and i think that
including indigenous voices is critical
because indigenous knowledge and
indigenous philosophy of taking care of
mother earth as a reciprocal action is
part of the paradigm shift that we need
to achieve
every one of us can and must deliver
actions at different scales and not only
political leaders business leaders
financial institutions everyone that has
a capacity of taking a decision those
decision makers they have the unique
opportunity of being part of the most
important challenge that we have ever
faced as a species i hope that you don't
lose hope i prayed on luzo i've seen
something you want to check out don't
check out don't give up don't give in
fight to the end whatever you do keep
fighting for this planet
huh it's gonna be a busy two weeks in
scotland a lot is on the line
let's take a look at another question we
got for david uh forgive me for
pronouncing your name wrong this is from
nitesh patel
what are the new technologies being
introduced to reduce carbon emissions
from industries ooh i love this question
this is a great question because this is
where the hope comes in right so uh
there are now new technologies that
allow us to produce green steel using
electricity or hydrogen instead of coal
there are new technologies to turn
cement you know the thing that's
building this building right here uh
from a carbon source into a carbon sink
so trapping that co2 in cement and then
we're also starting to develop let's
call them mechanical trees uh
technologies to pull carbon out of the
air and it's sort of a blend of the
natural and the technological because
you're harnessing geology
to pull that co2 back out you're just
speeding up the natural processes with
these machines so those are some of the
things that get me excited so you're
saying cyborgs yeah the solution are
cyborgs yeah something like that all
right
finally it is time to find out if rain
wilson and his friends ever found
anything funny about climate change
let's take a look
is there anything funny about climate
change given the
extreme weather we've had in recent
years that there are still some people
who claim it's a hoax
yeah that's hilarious
what's funny about climate change
[Music]
nothing
nothing is funny about climate change
climate change is like really not that
funny which is kind of funny i get to
sit around my house in my underwear i
swear to god i'm in my underwear i'm not
going to show you but i am i was
desperately looking for al gore's movie
on the environment and i walked into a
section of a store which was selling old
dvds do you have
an inconvenient truth they said yes
you're fat
because you eat too much
my mom used to say to me when i was
messing with something that i shouldn't
be messing with uh you're gonna put it
till it breaks and that's what we've
done with climate change with this
planet we have with it until it has
broken can we put it back together the
way that i promised my mother i could
put things back together when i was a
little kid all i needed some super glue
and a couple of hours to completely
reassemble this precious heirloom base
that you've had since you were a young
woman that i broke pretending to you
know do some kind of martial art that i
made up in my head uh
yeah no i don't know i wasn't able to
fix that face climate change kind of
reminds me of game of thrones when
they're warning everyone winter is
coming winter is coming but everyone in
king's landing all the hoy polloi is
like oh i wonder what's happening with
the lannisters and the starks and the
targaryens and we just continue
as though we're just dancing on the
titanic as it sinks well guess what
people's summer is coming
and it's coming hard
that's what she said
i think anything that happens once i'm
gone
not my problem
but then i got children
that's the part that makes it rough
uh
yeah
that's the killer for me i think
i got these kids and i want them to have
kids and
i'd like the species to continue so
but weren't for that
global warming would be hilarious
is there anything funny about climate
change no
it's a very serious matter i'm serious
i mean it's funny that some people
don't think it's a serious matter but
that's not like funny like ha ha it's
like funny like what the
this was a rough experiment i think we
may have just proven
empirically that there is
nothing funny about climate change okay
fine
maybe there's nothing funny about
climate change
let's
let's fix it
uh
see this is the process
but i'll find something just give me a
second
[Music]
thanks to rain and all his friends for
bringing the fun today
now we'd like to share another voice
from the countdown summit earlier this
month she's a poet activist artist
naima pennaman
i wonder if the sun
debates dawn some mornings not wanting
to rise out of bed from under the down
feather horizon
if the sky grows tired of being
everywhere at once adapting to the mood
swings of the weather
if clouds drift off china hold
themselves together
make deals with gravity to loiter a
little longer
i'll wonder
if rain is scared of falling if she has
trouble letting go
if snowflakes get sick of being perfect
all the time
each one trying to be
one of a kind i wonder if stars wish
upon themselves before they die
if they need to teach their young how to
shine
i wonder if shadows long to just for
once feel the sun
if they get lost in the shuffle not
knowing where they're from i wonder if
sunrise and sunset
respect each other even though they've
never met if storms have regrets if
volcanoes get stressed if compost
believes in life
after death
i wonder
if breath
ever thinks of suicide
if the wind just wants to sit still
sometimes and watch the world pass him
by
if smoke was born knowing how to rise if
rainbows get shy backstage
not sure if their colors match right
i wonder if lightning needs an alarm
clock to know when to crack if rivers
ever stop and think of turning back if
streams meet the wrong sea and their
whole lives run off track
i wonder if the snow
wants to be black
if the soil thinks she's too dark if
butterflies want to cover up their marks
if rocks are self-conscious of their
weight if mountains are insecure of
their strength
i wonder
if waves get discouraged crawling up the
sand only to be pulled back again to
where they began if land feels stepped
upon
if sand feels insignificant if trees
need to question their lovers to know
where they stand
if branches wave at the crossroads
unsure of which way
to grow
if leaves understand
they're replaceable
and they still dance when the wind blows
i
wonder where the moon goes when she is
in hiding i want to find her there and
watch the ocean spin from a distance
listen to her stir in her sleep
effort
give way
to existence
[Music]
thank you naima that last line effort
gives way to existence um david before
we go
what are the takeaways you want viewers
to watch from everything they've seen
today to to think about as they leave
well we've seen so many great talks but
i think
climate change is real it's here it's
happening now and it's us we're doing it
that's the hope though because we're
doing it it's not hopeless we know what
we need to do to change it we get to
decide what future we want
is it going to be worse
or how much better can it get
right
well thank you david uh thanks to all of
our incredible speakers
what we need now though
is not
more speeches it's more action
starting on a personal level switch to
leds ride public transport eat less meat
and dairy then go bigger
businesses you buy from politicians you
vote for your employer your neighborhood
speak up so they can hear you
join forces with others who are doing
the same
this is doable
so let's do it
before it
does us
in
thanks for watching and now once again
to take us home
charlie puths
thanks live um
i'm here today because
i myself am very passionate about
countdown's mission to create a world
that's safer cleaner and more just for
everyone
we all can help the count us in campaign
lays us out steps everyone can take
to start making positive changes for our
planet you can visit countdown.ted.com
to find out more
uh finally before we go i want to leave
you all with one more song here is my
song attention
[Music]
oh
tonight
you just wanna attention
you don't want mine
maybe you'll just see the thought of me
with someone new
yeah you just want attention
i know from the start
you're just making sure i'm never
getting over you
you've been running around running
around running around throwing that dirt
along
cause you knew that i knew that i'd know
that i'd call you
[Music]
i know that dress is karma but from
regret
it got me thinking about when you were
mine
and now i'm all up on you which you
expect but you're not coming with me
tonight
you just want attention
you don't remember
maybe you just see the thought of me
where someone knew
if you just want
[Music]
what are you doing
and now i'm all up
[Music]
you're just making sure
you